So let's talk more about the predict not-taken predictor, which is
the simplest predictor we can have. It amounts to simply incrementing the PC. So
this predictor is very simple because all it requires us is to increment the PC.
We know the PC from which we fetched the branch. We know how big the instruction
is. We can just increment the PC. So there is really no memory to
this predictor or anything else. We have to do the increment of the PC anyway.
Once we figure out it's not a branch, so this predictor pretty much uses
the hardware we have to have anyway. But the question is how accurate is it.
A rule of thumb is about 20% of all instructions are branches. So
80% of the time this predictor will be correct, because it's simply not a branch
instruction. For branches a little more over half of the branches are taken. So,
let's say, that 60% of branches are taken, so what we get is that
this predictor is correct. 80% of the time, for non branches. And also, another
8% of all the instructions because of the 40% of branches that are not taken.
It is incorrect, 12% of the time. It is incorrect,
60% of 20%, which amounts to 12%. Now, if we know the misprediction penalty,
we can easily compute, what is the impact. On CPI of branch mis-predictions.
The CPI will be one plus, 12% times the penalty.
In a five stage pipeline this would be two. So the CPI would be 1.24